welcome back guys to opengl part two my
name is matt you're watching code tech
tutorials
and we're gonna jump right into the code
and start doing some more
stuff so since last time we've made some
changes and i'm just gonna show you
those and all that stuff don't forget to
like comment subscribe and if you want
to support further you can join
the patreon which will all be linked
down below along with this source code
and let's get into it i hope to
elucidate all these
opengl things as we go some people have
expressed some concerns of
why opengl well there seems to be a lot
of demand for it and i want to do it my
own way
a lot of tutorials out there are just
tutorials of other tutorials and
i want to do things a little differently
and break down how i understand it
maybe that will uh help and i'm
definitely going to try to deviate
from the other stuff at least a little
now that way we get some original
stuff all right so for this update since
last time here's what we're going to be
doing we're going to be uploading meshes
this will be to the graphics card for
opengl to render
and we're going to be rendering meshes
and we're going to be also unloading
meshes so
if you want to like switch levels and
switch scenes and stuff switch assets
you definitely got to unload the old
ones otherwise you're going to have just
tons of space taken up for no particular
reason we're also going to be doing some
keyboard input stuff
stuff and we're going to be looking at
the viewport size and the
frame buffer resize so those are the
main things for this video
so to upload a mesh to opengl
you need to have a list of points and
i'm doing that
by making this vertex structure
so one thing we did is and if you're
following along you want to add a file
called vertex dot
h and this will hold a struct
that is just a vertex right now it only
has a position
an x y and z and a constructor so that
you can
set them as you create them but we will
be adding to this later this
is basically our placeholder for our
vertex
data and to get started positions good
enough
and we also have our draw details now
this is specific sort of to the
rendering i decided to keep it in this
file as well
because i don't know just seemed like it
fit here sort of
but this is basically what opengl needs
to know about to do its rendering and
there's a vao
which is a vertex array object and the
number of elements
so those are the main things we're going
to be using so these are just two
structs that we're going to be using
throughout
to help handle our data we're not going
to be using glm
a lot of people do use glm but i'm going
to skip over that at least for now we
might start using it later if we need to
depending depending on what uh how deep
we go because
some of the math that they abstract is
really nice and i don't really want to
have to rewrite that
but for now instead of a vec3 we're just
using
a float array with three and we're going
to do that
quite a bit it's just easy to handle
that data
okay well let's just go to our source
file here and we'll start
from the top and kind of walk through it
here
so i did add a clear color
this just sets the background to
something other than
black which is what it was before
and i am just creating
a vector of vertexes and that's
essentially our object is just a bunch
of different points each vertex is a
point
this is three points and it is enough
for a triangle
so the opengl screen is from each
corner negative one to one
so it's basically two units across
because it goes from negative one
to zero in the middle and then to one on
the other side
so with these points right here and just
using all the default shaders
we're using 0.5 because that'll go about
halfway across the screen
so like this point for example is 0.5 on
the x
so it's over to the right about halfway
and then negative 5 on the y
so that it's down i'm not sure this is
going to look right on the camera
i might be it might look opposite but
you'll get the point
so pun intended um maybe
maybe all right and so these are just
the three points of a triangle one on
the bottom right one on the bottom left
and one in the top middle
and we'll just see a little triangle and
then
we also want elements now
this is a really a
optimization uh when we're rendering
you can have an element array
that tells which points belong where
basically it tells you the faces
so every three of these is a face now
the reason we want to do this
is because sometimes you want to share
points like when you're making a square
for
example you do it out of two triangles
right
let me just draw this okay so just a
quick explanation here just to give you
a little data in case you don't know
this stuff
say this is your computer screen i know
it's all black but pretend it's your
computer screen
and you pop up an opengl window uh
looks something like this boom there you
say that's our
so that's our window and that's our
little screen space right there
so of course we would have the points as
i said right in the center as 0
0 for x and y and
down here is like negative 1 negative 1
and up here
is 1 1. so we're picking points
right there right there and right there
with those three points
that makes a triangle so that's
essentially all we're doing in
this tutorial
now the element buffers that i was
talking about
is another thing so if you want to draw
a square
usually you draw like a point here point
here point here
pretend those are lined up better and
you draw this one and then you do
mix another color and then you do like
point here
point here point here and draw another
one
and it essentially makes a square
um pretend that's a good square i know i
know it looks bad
but but the point of the element buffer
is you can reuse these right here
and without the element buffer you have
to declare them again
so any points that overlap like this
with the element buffers you can just
say oh
just use that one again because these
say
where to index so the zero one
will be the very first one this will be
the second one there's only three
because it's a triangle but if we added
a fourth one and wanted to make it
a square we would add one more of these
and then just
expand this one out it would be
something like well we used one and two
again and then we'd introduce one more
point
and so it'd be like
four one two and
while we're drawing two different faces
with points we still only have four
point sign these are wrong for the
square i'm just trying to make an
example for the future
so that's the whole point of these
element array buffers
so we set up our data here on the c plus
side
and then we send it to the graphics card
and that's what this upload mesh
function does here
so i've created this upload mess
function that takes a vertex
or a vector of vertexes and a vector of
unsigned ants for the elements so you
pass those in after you
create them you can also bring these in
from 3d models so if you're using 3d
modeling
software and you export it you can use
some kind of importer
get the points get the elements and
upload them with the same function
and it will work
at a very basic level
um and then this hard draw details we're
just making a
vector of draw details there's only
going to be one in here but this is i'm
making it in a way so that you can add
more than one to
it because later when we go to draw we
pass in
a vector of details and it basically
renders all this stuff
so let's go ahead and do this uh upload
mesh function i want to talk about it
real quick
so i did create a folder called
rendering and and i put opengl
draw.h and opengl loader so this upload
mesh is part of the loader let's go
ahead and look at that
and you'll see there's two different
functions in here there's a upload mesh
and there's unload mesh and now now that
i'm looking at it i realize how close
those names are so it's
maybe not the best naming scheme but you
can tell them a different tell them
apart because the upload mesh
takes more stuff and it returns draw
details
so when you call this upload mesh
and you pass it a reference to your
vertexes and a
reference to your elements and then just
make sure those aren't empty
because we don't want to have empty
arrays of either of those for what we're
doing
and then we go through the upload
process now this is the process you kind
of generically see on every tutorial but
i'm going to go ahead and walk through
it real quick
just to make sure it's all understood
because it is a little bit complicated
to understand
and it can be a barrier for some people
so hopefully this
upcoming explanation that i do here will
help someone
and uh that's the whole goal this is to
help people
understand this okay so what we're going
to do here is use the opengl
library to push up to the graphics card
so all these functions are abstracted
from opengl
uh they've already written all the hard
code to do all this stuff all we got to
do is
call them in the correct order basically
so i'm going to explain them
now all right so first of all we're
going to just hold a few
identifiers and you'll see why we need
these in a second
some of these are temporary the only one
we're going to save is the vao
these others are just placeholders for
now
what we do here and i'll go back to the
drawing board real quick
uh let's just make a new one so what we
do here is we make a vao
and a vao it's basically a matrix
and you should know what a matrix is if
you do coding stuff
it's just multiple arrays well it starts
out with just nothing you declare it and
it's just like an empty one
but what we're going to do is we're
going to
bind this vbo which is a vertex buffer
object
which is part of it so this whole thing
is a vao but we're going to have a
little parts of it that are like
a vbo and we're also going to make
another little part of it later
called an ebo and you can expand it
further
but our vao is just going to have these
few things for now and these are
basically just arrays of data
this vbo is going to end up being
all our positions and if we expand those
vertexes later it will include more
stuff in it too
like maybe positions normals texture
coordinates
and all that but for right now it's just
going to be all our positional stuff
and we'll talk about more of it later
and the ebo or element buffer
object elements and indexes or indices
are used interchangeably they all mean
the same thing basically
opengl calls them elements this is just
going to be
an index you know it's just going to be
a bunch of unsigned ants
the vao is going to hold both of these
it's the whole point
and uh yeah that's basically how it
works so first of all
we generate the vertex arrays for vao
and this
returns an id for this vao so after
calling this
gen vertex arrays right here our vao
now has an id and it's not zero
and then we go ahead and bind the one we
just created now binding basically
means uh you're working with that one so
when you bind it you are now working on
that one
so your next calls or your next stuff
will all
work on that bao so now that we're on
that vo
video and have it bound we're going to
generate some buffers for a vbo
just one and we're going to bind
this vbo as an array buffer
and then we're going to buffer data and
this buffer data is what actually does
the like the send to the graphics card
so uh when we buffer we tell it what
type it's an array buffer
then we also do have to do the size and
memory
let's see if i can hover over this and
get a little call out
okay well this is the size and memory
and you can get the size and memory by
doing
the size of this uh vector
so it's the verts.size so if there's
like 20 of them it'll be 20.
and then we're going to times that all
by the size of each vertex so this size
of
will return you how large in memory a
vertex is
so for each one we just times it by the
size of it basically
and now we have the size of all that
data
and then we want a pointer to the start
of the data
and you can get that when using a vector
by
using the dot data you could optionally
if you're if you're doing it with an
array
and vectors are raised the dot data just
gets the start of an array
you can do it something like this too
you see this a lot
which is just a reference to the first
element that's also a pointer to the
start of the array
but we're going to stick with verts.data
here and then we're using static draw
because we are not going to change this
these points once they're uploaded so we
call it static
and that's generally what you're going
to be using there
and then we will be transforming them at
some point
and that is different from changing the
points up there the points
on the card stay the same all right and
next
we enable these vertices basically so we
want to tell it
jail vertex or trip pointer the zeroth
one so the very first one basically
it's three elements and that's because
it's a position it's an x y and z and
it's also a float
it's not normalized and
it wants the size of each individual one
so it's just the size of a vertex
the size of each individual set of
positions
so the size of a vertex this vertex is a
struct
that you know we looked at it earlier
but all it holds is basically this right
here so the size
is just going to return the size of
three floats essentially
since that's the only thing in the
struct
so the size of each of those three
points is the size of a vertex that's
basically how that works there
and now here we have an offset
now this basically wants a pointer to
the start of the data
um so to get that from a struct you can
use offset of
and then pass it your what struct object
and then the name of
the member yeah member
instruct and then you want to cast that
to a const void star
so you can use offset of if you have
multiple pieces of data in there like
for example if we eventually have
a texture in there too we would use the
same offset of and just put
that in there like that and we'd have to
adjust everything else but it'd be like
the next one we will get to that we're
just not going to do that in this
tutorial
right now we're only working with those
positions and then you need to enable
that trib array by saying enable
whichever one it was it's
0 1 enable it so now that's enabled on
the bao
and that's all done we're done with
those points
now we just want to upload these
elements and you do that in a very
similar way you generate a buffer for
the ebo
then you bind it and make sure you bind
it as an element buffer
or element array buffer and then when
you buffer the data you also got a
dual element array buffer that way it
knows and
also the size of it is once again going
to be a very similar thing it's just the
size of
the vector times the size of each data
member and then we get a pointer to the
start of the data it's also static draw
and then uh we're essentially done but
one thing you want to do at the end just
to clean up
is bind vertex array 0.
that is like the one the default one
because up here
we bound our vao which is not zero
and we worked with it but once you're
done working with
a vertex buffer you want to bind zero
when you're all done that way you don't
mess up something else later in your
program which is good practice and then
we're going to delete the vbo
and the ebo because we don't need them
anymore they're already all set up
the trip pointer is all set up and it's
enabled
and the ebo is there as an element
arraybuffer it knows how to use all that
stuff
now that it's all uploaded so we can
delete those we do need to save this vao
so we're not going to delete it
until we're completely done with the
data so we're going to go ahead and just
return
the draw details and so to draw later
what you're going to need to remember is
the vao
and the size of the elements because
that's you want to tell how many to draw
so that's what we construct there with
draw details and then return to the user
and you see this is just a struct
and it has two unsigned ends and it's
something we can expand
later if we need to and that is
it for the upload mesh
so now that we have it uploaded and we
have returned a set of draw details
there's now one you
one uh thing in our vector here of draw
details
and we continue on and we enter our
while loop
so when we go into our while loop i went
ahead and added a process input function
i just put that in the new file here
called
input.h so you'll need to create an
input input.h if you're following along
and all this is is a static void process
input that takes a window
uh glfw window pointer and when you call
this
it just checks if a a key is pressed and
you can
make this whatever key you want and do
all sorts of stuff here to your program
but the only thing we're going to do is
check for a press of escape
and set the window that it should close
to true
this doesn't actually close the window
it just says hey the next time you check
this window is supposed to close and
that's for us to handle and that is what
we handle right here in this while loop
at the top
so if you press escape the next time it
tries to start this loop it's going to
say up
we need to close just continue on and
once it gets to terminate it does
actually finally close but
we'll talk about that here in a second
so we process the input you won't have
any input the very
very first run but you'll get it real
quick because at the end of every loop
we pull for events again
in the start of the next move process
all right so what we do here is a gl
clear on the color buffer bit and this
will set it to whatever color you have
set on this gl clear color
and we want to reset this every time
before we render
that way it goes it goes ahead and sets
the background if you don't do this
clear
everything just starts stacking on top
of each other and never clears and it's
just your screen becomes a mess so you
got to clear before every draw
and then we draw using our details now
if we go ahead and take a look at this
draw function
i put it in this opengl draw dot h
under the rendering folder and all it
does is as you can see here it takes a
const reference to our draw details
vector
we only have one thing in it right now
but if you want to make a bunch of
different objects
and put them all in here it'll render
it'll just go through and render them
all
so it's just something that's easily
expandable so that you can draw scenes
later with this sort of function
and something you can keep expanding on
that's one of the points i kind of want
to reiterate as i go through this
tutorial is often we want to design
things in a way where it's expandable
later so i'm trying to explain in a way
where you know
or kind of have an understanding of how
to expand it and that's
that's the thing i think a lot of other
opengl tutorials kind of don't
really talk about or lead on towards and
something i want to do differently so
let me know what you guys think about
that
okay so anyway we just iterate through
every one of our details
and for each one of them we bind the vao
so we're working with that one and then
we call draw
elements as triangles for however many
elements
and they're all this is an unsigned end
and null pointer just means at the start
of our elements so you can change
this final thing to say oh only draw
like the second half or some middle
portion of my elements it's kind of a
niche thing to do usually you want to
draw them all if you're drawing but
there are some weird optimizations
people do with this
so this draw elements work specifically
when you're uploading with
the element array method and that is
standard
if you export an object from anything it
always
uh does it with the indices or elements
because it's
more efficient that way so
a lot of tutorials teach you how to do
it with just points
and don't even talk about elements and
then after doing that they say okay now
here's how you optimize it so i'm kind
of skipping over that point just fyi and
i'm going straight to the elements
okay and that's all that does is it
binds and draws every
one that we have set up and then when
we're all done after we're done with
that for loop
we once again bind vertex array zero
this is always good practice
if you're binding somewhere when you're
all done bind back to zero
okay so that handles drawing now the
thing about drawing
is it draws to your back buffer you
don't actually see it
until you call glfw's flop buffers
because that'll swap whatever you're
drawing to the front
and then the pool events is just a glfw
thing to check for all the key presses
and
then while the next loop will process
those and that'll just continue it's not
actually going to do anything because
it's just
you know it's just an object on the
screen and then when we're all done
and we leave we just call unload mesh
on all of our draw details so this is
another function i made in the opengl
loader just called unload mesh and all
this does
is it just takes it just goes through
all those details
um and deletes every vao that we've
created
and then it uh also clears our all
details with
details talk clear so this unload mesh
is pretty
pretty destructive it destroys you know
everything on the graphics card that you
had uploaded from these drawer details
and then it clears the vector
but that's what you want to do when
you're all done with it and you might
have them sectioned off
you know if you're doing like a game or
something you might have like oh here's
all like
specific elements for just level three
for example
and when we're all done we want to
unload all those elements for level
three so
you typically won't have one giant array
of everything usually you'll have them
sectioned as like
here's objects that only render when
you're
really close and here's one you know
stuff like that there's a lot of
different ways to do it and you'll have
to play around with optimizations
depending on
how your stuff is structured but that's
like a broad overview
there and then of course after we're all
done with that we just called glfw
terminate now it is
notable it says someone might eventually
say something like you don't need to do
the delete thing
well no you don't because you're just
leaving the program and it's going to
you know clean up after itself when you
completely leave anyway
but it's just good practice because it's
something you need to know and if you're
doing graphics
at some point you're going to be wanting
to like switch levels or load different
things as part of your it's uh you know
the old static
single window thing is only the hello
world it's when you're really getting in
digging in yeah you're gonna you're
gonna be doing all sorts of
neat stuff and another thing we did
which i haven't mentioned yet is we set
the frame buffer
size callback and so all this does
is it helps adjust the size of our
viewport so when we first launch our
window
let's go ahead and launch it now i think
i've said enough and there it is
so there's everything we set up let me
just show you this function here
so there it is all it is is a function
it's got to be of this signature
uh it takes one a glw window pointer and
a width and a height
integer and you can do whatever you want
here the only thing we really need to do
is just call
gl viewport zero zero and the new width
and the new height
so when you set this callback
jofw the frame buffer size callback
anytime you resize the window
it calls this function so i'm just going
to show you without it
what it does we resize our window
our viewport stays in the same place
which is just the bottom left
and also stays the same size set frame
buffer size callback
and change the gl viewport now zero zero
these first two numbers
it's just the bottom left where you want
the bottom left to be and zero zero is
the bottom left
now this viewport space is different
from the opengl space that i was talking
about
before say for example
uh this is your screen and
an opengl space which is like the model
world space zero zero is in the center
but in viewport space
0 0 is at the bottom left so it's like
right here
so like okay there's zero zero and then
you set the
port size to whatever you say the width
so it just starts at zero zero
that's really it's not really that big
of a thing it's just something you kind
of need to be aware of otherwise you're
just going to get confused
at some point and that's it that is all
the code let me know what you guys think
i'm always reading and listening to you
guys
i'll see you in the next episode peace
[Music]
[Music]
out
[Music]
you